well I give you an example I worked on a
movie called awakenings and with Robert
De Niro and Robin Williams and was
fantastic to watch Robert in the
auditioning process because he read with
a lot of other actors and the way he
grew from the first audition to the last
one that we did together because you
know he paid he played somebody who
shook quite a bit and watching him do
that watching him create a character in
the audition because he's many weeks we
read with a lot of different actors I
thought that was fascinating and I could
see him writing down on his script
little things that he thought about and
his script was filled with like little
notes I think that's a big part of it
that you you put yourself inside that
person and create a character and maybe
sometimes you can't even come out of it
another instance was well I was working
with Al Pacino and and I he was
directing and and and I brought in this
actor from Chicago to play a bartender
and al said would you mind reading with
me and he said no not at all I'd love to
and I saw I'll take his hat and turn it
in such a way and his his posture
changed and it was almost as if Al
Pacino had walked out of the room in
this case
character was sitting in the room I had
never seen anything quite like that but
he was he understood that character so
much that I would imagine that he would
be doing that almost daily in different
ways when he would think about something
or how the character would sit or what
he would be thinking it was just a
remarkable physical thing it was it was
truly amazing he he twisted his head he
his his shoulders went down his body
language was different and he became the
character and Al Pacino literally walked
out of the room so I think there's a way
to get inside a character that I think
is it's it's unbelievable to me I mean
when a curtain goes up on stage and
you're transported into a whole of the
world in these incredible human beings
are playing these characters I just
don't know how they do it you know I
just don't know how they do it I think
it's remarkable but but I'm talking
about people are really committed and
and and and great
you